بعد الصدمه الاوليه تحاول هذه الشركه
المختصه في قطاع الاتصالات تعويض غياب
مهندسي البرمجيات الذين غادروا البلاد
والحصول على قطع الغيار المحظور تصديرها
الى روسيا فضلا عن تغطيه الفراغ الذي حصل
في القطاع بعد ان انسحبت عشرات الشركات من
السوق مهمه عصيه لكنها ليست مستحيله وفق
تعبيرهم
استطعنا الحصول على قطع غيار عبر قنوات
بديله ولا نزال نعاني نقصا في عدد
التقنيين
كل هذا يزيد حجم الضغط علينا خاصه ان عددا
كبيرا من الشركات غادرت البلد
من بين الذين غادروا البلاد اكثر من 100
الف متخصص في تكنولوجيا المعلومات لجاوا
الى دول غربيه نزيف تصبو روسيا الى ايقافه
عبر حزمه من الاجراءات
عن فرض قيود على موظفي البرمجه الذين
يعملون عن بعد لصالح شركات روسيه لان اي
قيود ستدفع بهم للعمل في شركات اجنبيه
وعدم العوده الى البلاد
امام الحواجز الاوروبيه عثرت بعض الشركات
الناشئه على اسواق بديله في الشرق الاوسط
واسيا ولتفادي فقدان طاقمها سارعت الى
اتخاذ اجراءات عاجله
من توفير حصانه خاصه للعاملين في مجال
البرمجه لتفادي التعبئه في الجيش وهو محل
دون مغادره موظفين وممكن شركتنا من تفادي
نقص الكوادر
يعترف المسؤولون الروس بقسوه العقوبات
التي استهدفت قطاعهم التكنولوجي لكنهم
يرون ايضا ان تلك العقوبات دفعتهم
للاعتماد على النفس واستثمار مواردهم على
نحو غير مسبوق للوصول الى استقلال
تكنولوجي يؤمن مصالح المواطنين والشركات
ايمن الزبير الجزيره موسكو